في البومها الذهبي جدل حول حذف الجابريه
رحله 422 وتفاعل مع اقتراب موسم دراما
رمضان اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
ستنتهي ستنتهي ستنتهي الحرب وضعت مؤسسه
الشعر الفلسطينيه الراحل محمود درويش
كارول سماحه فيما وصف على منصات التواصل
بالورطه حينما اعلنت ان اغنيه ستنتهي
الحرب التي اصدرتها كارول مؤخرا ليست من
كلمات الشاعر الراحل وانما من انتاج مواقع
التواصل وهي دون المستوى المعروف به
شاعرنا الكبير بحسب البيان الذي طالب
سماحه وشركائها في الانتاج بوقف النشر
وحذف كل ما يتعلق بنسبها لمحمود درويش
[موسيقى]
من جهتها نشرت الفنانه اللبنانيه كارلوس
سماحه بيانا صادرا عن محاميها قالت فيه ان
كلمات اغنيه ستنتهي الحرب نسبت في اكثر من
مصدر ومرجع الى الشاعر محمود درويش كما هو
ثابت على المواقع الالكترونيه منذ زمن
بعيد واقر البيان بانه بعد التدقيق
والتعمق والمراجعه تبين ان كلمات الاغنيه
من التراث والملك العام ونص البيان الصادر
عن محامي سماحه انها ستعمد لاحقا لتصويب
الامر منعا لاي التباس او استغلال وهو ما
لم يحدث حتى تاريخه فلا يزال اسم الشاعر
محمود درويش يتصدر كليب اغنيه ستنتهي
الحرب التي نشرتها سماحه عبر قناتها
الرسميه على يوتيوب وهي احدى اغنيات
البومها الجديد الذي اطلقت عليه اسم
الالبوم الذهبي وكراسته بالكامل لغناء
قصائد لدرويش
وعلى سيره البيانات اشارت وزاره الاعلام
الكويتيه في بيان نشرته عبر حسابها الرسمي
على تويتر بحذف مسلسل الجابريه الرحله 422
من منصه شاهد دون اي توضيح من المنصه وذلك
بعد عرض ثلاث حلقات منه البيان الذي لم
ينشر الى المسلسل بالاسم تم نتجاوب
المسؤولين في احدى المنصات الخليجيه
بالغاء عرض مسلسل قالت الوزاره انه يسيء
للكويت ورموزها الحذف الذي لم تعلن اسبابه
بشكل رسمي اثار موجدا من التكهنات بين
الرواد منصات التواصل في الكويت الاسبوع
الماضي تحت وسم الجابريه الرحله 422 تبانت
فيه الاراء حول حقيقه هذه الاسباب وخمن
البعض انها تعود لطريق التجسيد شخصيه
الاميرين الراحلين الشيخ جابر الاحمد
الصباح والشيخ سعد العبد الله السالم
الصباح في المسلسل ويتناول حادثه اختطاف
طائره الجابريه الكويتيه القادمه من
بانكوك سنه
1988 والتي استمرت وقتها 16
يوما
وعلى صعيد اخر اعلنت مجموعه ام بي سي ان
مسلسل معاويه ما زال قيد التحضير انتاجيا
وفنيا وسيتم الاعلان عن موعد عرضه بمجرد
ان يصبح جاهزا وذلك في اول تعليق رسمي على
الجدل حول عرض المسلسل في رمضان المقبل
والذي يجسد فيه الفنان السوري لجين
اسماعيل شخصيه مؤسسه الدوله الامويه بعدما
جسد شخصيه الشيخ محي الدين ابن عربي في
مسلسل مقامات العشق وستحضر دراما
التاريخيه على قائمه العروض الرمضانيه هذا
الموسم من خلال المسلسل المصري رساله
الامام عن سيره حياه الامام الشافعي الذي
يجسد شخصيته الفنان خالد النبوي تحت اداره
المخرج السوري الليث حجو النفع
نزلو الا في الطمع
واخيرا وعلى سيره المسلسلات حققت
البوسترات والاعلانات الترويجيه للاعمال
الدراميه التي ستعرض مع انطلاقه موسم
العرض الرمضاني اواخر الشهر الحالي الكثير
من التفاعل على منصات التواصل في العالم
العربي واثار البوستر الاوليه للمسلسل
المصري تحت الوصايه من بطوله منى زكي
انتقادات البعض في مصر بدعوى الاساءه لشكل
المراه المحجبه قبل ان تكشف الشركه
المنتجه عن البوستر الرسمي للعمل كما قبل
الاعلان عن الجزء السابع من مسلسل الكبير
اوي من خلال اغنيه بلعانه التي اطلقها نجم
العمل احمد مكي بحفاوه كبيره وسادت حاله
من الترقب على مواقع التواصل حول طبيعه
الشخصيه التي يجسدها الفنان السوري مكسيم
خليل في مسلسل ابتسم ايها الجنرال من
تاليف الكاتب السوري سامي رضوان الشهيد
نصوصه الاشكاليه والجماهيريه في انم معك